hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to quite an
important unboxing uh probably not for
you guys as important but it's very
important for me because it's going to
help you guys see a lot more content
from me in the future
this is actually a microphone stand that
i actually couldn't wait to get so i
purchased from b h since we got such a
great deal on that
so i'm just going to go ahead and unbox
it for you guys like i said it means a
lot to me because it means i'm going to
be able to pump out a lot more uh very
high quality content for you guys
instead of as you guys could tell i
wasn't putting out a lot of videos
because it was inconvenient to use the
microphone that i have
so now that i've found this microphone
stand
which sits on your desk it should be
really easy to just
sit down
plug in the microphone and to begin
recording and editing a video
so let's just get right on into this
this just looks like packing information
and
packing
stuff
and it's very heavy also i believe it's
uh
i believe it's made of iron i guess some
sort of cast iron material but as you
can see this is a
samson
uh desktop mic stand
it says at the bottom fixed five inch
height
solid die cast base stand for stability
durable uh finish and it's really heavy
so uh
just go right ahead and take a look into
this
by uh opening up the box here's the
front of it there's a good look at it
actually
says the md5 which is the the the name
of the mic
it's gonna be really really close to me
and uh be able to get the best quality
out of my recording let's see what we
can do here
all right so we can
what looks like
pull this out here like i said you guys
will notice after this
unboxing quite an increase in the
quality of my content as well as how
frequently it comes out so that's
the end of what's in the box
all you have is the microphone stand and
the base
so i'm just going to go ahead and take
this over sorry about the color quality
also this is just a quick unboxing video
so it doesn't look very accurate colors
but there you guys can see it's kind of
a concave base there and i'll tell you
what that's very heavy metal material
it's gonna be sitting on my desk so
that's really heavy and then what else
we have in the bottom here
is the microphone stand as it twists
into the base
you also be able to see that says
samsung stands samsontech.com
what i believe we can do is
twist that right in there
and that's about all we need to do
all we can do right after that is put
the microphone stand on or the
microphone itself on top attach the pop
filter do whatever we need to do and we
are pretty much set to go with this
microphone stand so thanks for checking
out this unboxing video you guys will be
able to get a lot more content in the
future
previously it was really inconvenient to
record because well i would have to
stand up next to the vocal booth and i
wouldn't be able to see my screen while
recording
so voiceovers were a little bit more
difficult but now they'll be way more
consistent frequent and a little bit
easier for me so expect good higher
quality content so thanks for watching
this quick unboxing video and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one so thanks
for watching peace
you